When I was in university, I hated Python. Butnow
that I'm in my career, I absolutely love it. This
video are the top reasons why devs likeme and
many others love Python. First one is that it
is so easy to learn. And when I startedlearning
Python, I was in university and was learning it
informally because I was assignedsome work that
required Jupyter notebooks. At the time I hated
it because I was forced to useit and I remember
being particularly annoyed by the fact that it
used the word "none" instead of "null". However,
I was really versed with Java and C at the time,
and so when I got more and more used toit, it
started feeling like executable pseudocode. This
is mainly because Python is a typelesslanguage
and it's also an interpreted language.And what
this means is basically that Pythoncuts a lot of
corners and handles a lot of things for you. And
so for developers, whereyou would typically
get compile-time errors,you're going to get
runtime errors with Python.And so you just need
to be cognizant of that.But everyone deals with
that. And so thatleads us into reason two, the
community.There's a huge community for Python.
It has beenaround for nearly 30 years now.
And so with that time there has been so many
tutorials and forumscreated. No matter what
you're dealing with,whether you're learning
Python or dealingwith a certain concept in
your code,there's probably a tutorial that
walksyou through it or a forum where
hundreds of people have asked the same
question before. And then on top of that, if
you have a problem that no one has asked yet,
you can askit and someone will probably get
back to you. So the community is great. But next,
welove that Python has a virtual environment.
And what virtual environments allow is fordevs
to encapsulate all of their scriptsand libraries
into one portable environment. At IBM, I've used
Python many different times for many different
projects, and with each projectit has its
own virtual environment. This way I could switch
between the two environments and nothave to worry
about the different libraries and dependencies
that go with each. Now, in a previousvideo I
talked about cloud migration and how we used Python
scripts to analyze performance metrics. With that,
we created a virtual environment for that project
and I encapsulated it and shippedit off to the
rest of my teammates. This way we all have a
consistent environment to run thecode and can get
consistent answers. Lastly, us devs love Python
for its versatility. Now Pythonis a general
purpose language and so it can be used across
many different platforms, everythingfrom your
mobile devices to laptops to servers.Python
has got you covered. And with Pythonbeing
versatile and having a huge community, there's
libraries for nearly anything youcan think
of. I've personally used Python to develop some
natural language processing, someAI development,
some numerical analysis, and even automated stock
trading. So with IBM-- er sorry --with Python
being across different platforms, having so many
different libraries and a greatcommunity, there's
so much you can do with it. Now, Python's not
going to be great when youneed to tell a computer
where to put those 1's and 0's. However, for the
vast majorityof other things that you need to
deal with, Python has got you covered. Thanks for
watching.If you like this content, be sure to
like and subscribe. If you're new to Python and
wantto learn more, check out the links below.